I'm glad that I didn't know about the
YouTube 10 minute every like Intel yeah
you watched the whole thing the whole
series of whatever if you were lucky I I
just remember that I I realized like up
until I was a teenager I'd just pretty
much never watched a full series of
anything because it was always scattered
on TV right you would never you would
never get to watch it in the parts or in
the order it was intended and I kind of
had this Revelation when I was like oh
my God this is so much better when I can
watch it in order and all of it this is
amazing I felt like went on this like
insane watching spree where I didn't
play any video games even though I was
addicted to video games I would just
spend all day watching like Box series I
was online because I was just like oh my
God you can watch things in order wow
for free that's kind of a cool I mean
I'm glad that that happened because like
my parents the only DVDs they would ever
buy was uh of the movies and stuff so I
only ever got to watch movies in
completion TV shows I often never got to
see where they went ever right no yeah
same here because when you know in the
era of TV
um like we couldn't really like I
couldn't really afford DVD
so you watch what you got on TV and that
didn't necessarily mean if you missed
the week then you just had to like deal
with the fact that you missed the week
you know and I think that's why you know
back when I was growing up I think
that's why Pokemon was so popular
because it has a storyline but you can
jump in most episodes
back then because you know yeah you
pretty missed 10 episodes and yeah yeah
I fear that for me though
that ship has sailed I I feel I I've
tried to get into it because I know that
you guys are you you've talked about it
a lot and I know that a lot of the
people who I interact with now who like
Japan are interested in it she's an
angel like sports traumatized
whatever happened to it the copy I
actually think that somewhere in
Missouri if you lift up a certain panel
on the ceiling you'll find the actual
porn VHS that my friend splice together
from like Cinemax or yeah whatever and
he distributed it out to all the Buddies
back when we were 13 or something and
that shine VHS one of your friends
sliced a porn video you don't you don't
know the struggle at all I remember back
in the day you would he yeah so Cinemax
or skinamax is what we called it or HBO
none of us had subscriptions to this
because it was expensive but if you did
they would there was like he would make
it look nice it'd like the video would
start and it would be like Orion films
which had nothing to do with like the
porn stuff but he'd use like he'd record
that part from like a movie and then
he'd be like oh what are we getting
today this is gonna be exciting and then
that was the only porn you had for a
year that was it or if you I remember
when I was a kid I got a computer I got
like you know this this thing and it had
a printer and I I was like oh man I can
get like a picture of like Carmen
Electra naked or something and I was
like print and then it would be like
yeah I'd be like oh in three hours this
shit's gonna be good
and then it would get like it'd be like
the sun you know and you see like a blue
sky and they didn't keep going and
you're like oh it's getting there and
then it'd be like Elmo from Sesame
Street like what the [__] I didn't
that's not what I downloaded and then it
was like not what you got yeah you use
like 22 of your ink from the uh that was
really expensive your mom's gonna kill
you well you know I boys will be boys
um but like and then we had the whole
era of of Kaza and LimeWire which is
um I thought I found your ninja actually
well well you could have just asked me
for my time
I remember trying to like download like
a episode of something and I was like
this is this
this is a Naruto
it was always Shin angel or Bible black
that was that was the only two Choice it
was like specifically [__] Angel episode
two and it was only episode two that was
available on LimeWire I have no idea why
all right was that the one with the girl
who was jumping off the roof yeah
I was like this is bringing back a cool
memory I've completely forgotten I was
never I was never old enough or
intelligent enough to figure out how to
use the computer at the period when line
while I was around my brother was right
brother was yeah and I remember my
brother getting absolutely murdered by
my parents because he downloaded in just
the most so many viruses oh yeah it was
basically unusable yeah I just remember
just my dad just screaming at my brother
and me being like what's going on why is
why is Hillary Clinton uh why is Bill
Clinton talking yeah Bill Clinton
every time you'd get you'd search for
something oddly specific for example big
boobied woman threes yeah
random one yeah and then you'd get you'd
wait like two days yeah because it has
to be seated yeah yeah and then you'd
hit play and hit show Bill Clinton go I
did not have sex relations with that
woman that is legit the best trolls
before Rick rolls yeah right so you'd be
like whoever whoever was the first guy
who came up with that literally the best
trolling internet
it was awful and so you and then I
remember reformatting your PC was a
regular thing you'd have a friend who
knows how to do it yeah and we'd be like
I heard Windows 98 version two is way
better than Windows XP and we'd be like
let's [__] do that then let's get a
cracked version of this and then we'll
do that and it was like that's why when
you say I didn't grow up with the
internet era I feel like I you know that
was the beginning yeah yeah for sure
like I think what separates that in my
mind because when I was growing up it
was sort of like this where it was like
there was this there was this moment
when you were done with the computer and
you logged off oh yeah and then it was
that was it it yeah yeah whereas now
it's like you are always online yeah and
so in my mind that's where like the
notable switch is is like when it was
more accessible in your phone and every
app was on there and you know now it
suddenly became where you used to have
to log on to MSN or log on to these chat
rooms to try and chat now it's like oh
you can reach me anytime yeah that's
where I felt like the internet became
what it is today yeah and before that
was kind of the wild west where it was
like Hey if you're online we chatted if
you if you weren't whatever you're like
AOL Instant Messenger was the big one
and it even had like the door opening
sound when you'd have a list of all the
contacts like you said and it'd be like
you you just message them well you they
usually had an away message up or they
it would be like they wouldn't be on the
online list so what you hear that and
then you would you'd be like oh who was
that that just logged in all right oh
cool and then you'd talk to them for two
or three hours yeah but then they'd be
like I gotta go and be like and you're
like well okay and you can customize the
sounds and yeah man that was um that was
some fun stuff but I think that we're in
a nice place now where now there's a
platform for everybody to do what any
anything and everything that they've
ever wanted so that's pretty cool good
or bad that's good all that yeah it's
it's it's uh there's a good points and
those bad points be connected all the
time you know I mean I feel like now
there was a big separation between what
you did online and what you did outside
of the internet and now that sep that
that war is just getting like thinner
and thinner every year dude serial
experiments Lane said that [__] like 20
years ago and they were right they were
[__] right no [__] right yeah but
I did bring uh one small thing just so
and we're gonna put it at the very
bottom of all this mess it's not a shin
Angel toy oh oh God damn it I I couldn't
get it this is this is my hat I'll wear
in a second I guess but I feel like the
real anime that never gets talked about
is is my guys from Ninja Turtles so I'm
going to leave that down near the bottom
so that there's some American
representation
we have LeBron James LeBron James
another another representation okay look
we have LeBron James all right get that
back we'll put that near the bottom near
that banana oh look
out of here
but yeah that's then
that's a cool toy restaurant
but I was like that's that's Pixar it's
not anime or it's not animation cartoons
are different like those so you go so I
felt like you need something because I
don't understand any of what's Happening
Here and honestly this is giving me well
you know what would you like to know
would you like to know does this invoke
ah besides the thing I watched with my
mother this looks like see this looks
like some Naruto [__] I don't know that
[__]
she looks like the hidden ninjas like
welcome to the end and I'll serve you up
a pork tonight or whatever you poor
naive child and then you've got the the
one in the Middle with the spear yeah
that's like some hardcore you know
oh it's a katana yes that's like a the
nodachi it's like the big one yeah man
let me tell you about fake Pete oh
that's fate that's where they have uh uh
a God that's not funny you'd be
surprised this is this is fake oh God
wait this is fate this is funny yeah
that other one is also yeah you just
picked up picked up two fakers well
Grand order of the Marshalls or whatever
I know this [__] it's like you could
have stopped at Grandma yeah you were
halfway there now what's the full name
again fake Grand order xr2 uh this time
it's serious but like I know because
it's a regular person and then they'll
have like Athena or some historical
person like Abraham Lincoln or some [__]
yeah
cute anime girl right yeah I didn't know
that they were saying them like
historical yeah the King Arthur is like
a like a hot chick oh wait you see that
character over there this one that's
King Arthur that's King Arthur I thought
that was I thought
she's not the girl who knows King Arthur
no
that's King Arthur yeah
it's
like Genghis Khan or something Nebraska
okay